Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“迈向经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. How can we begin to move towards a society where there is zero suicide? What sort
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由丽莎本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的 Linktree 页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。我们该如何迈向一个零自杀的社会？我们应该与所爱之人，
of conversations should we be having both with those we love or those that we work with if we work in mental health? These are all the questions that we are going to be discussing in today's episode and more. I am chatting with Steve Phillips, father of Jordan and the founder of the Jordan Legacy and everything that we can do as a community, as a movement, as an organization, as a country to begin to move towards zero suicide. I hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Today, I know that if you're watching on YouTube, I do look like I
或者如果我们从事心理健康工作，应该与我们的服务对象进行什么样的对话？这些都是我们今天节目要讨论的问题，甚至更多。我将与乔丹（Jordan）的父亲、乔丹遗产组织（The Jordan Legacy）的创始人史蒂夫·菲利普（Steve Phillips）进行交谈，探讨作为一个社区、一个运动、一个组织、一个国家，我们能做些什么来迈向零自杀。希望这期节目对你有帮助。你好，欢迎来到《有抱负的心理学家》（Aspiring Psychologist）播客。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天，我知道如果你在 YouTube 上观看，我看起来
have been in the wars a little bit. And if you're listening and you don't know what I'm on about, I have got a large white patch on my face because I had a mole removed this week and they've told me I've got to keep this on for seven whole days which wasn't something that I was really planning on. I just thought I'd have some small stitches and that would be quite discreet and nobody would notice but that is not the way. Reminds me of when I broke my arm last year and then we had the poorly wing series. Now we will have the which stage of Marianne's mold treatment are we at? But today is such an important conversation. This episode is launching as close to World Suicide Prevention Day as possible. But this is not just a conversation
有点像刚经历过一场恶战。如果你是在收听音频，不知道我在说什么，我的脸上贴着一块大大的白色贴布，因为我这周刚切除了一颗痣，医生告诉我必须贴上整整七天，这完全不在我的计划之内。我本以为只是缝几针，会很隐蔽，没人会注意到，但事实并非如此。这让我想起去年我摔断胳膊时，我们做的“受伤的翅膀”系列。现在我们要开始“玛丽安的祛痣治疗进行到哪一步了？”系列。但今天的话题非常重要。这期节目发布的时间尽可能接近“世界预防自杀日”。但这不仅仅是
for September. You may be discovering this months, perhaps even years later. It's an incredibly powerful episode, of course, because we are talking about suicide. This might feel triggering, so please do look after yourself. And if you are listening around young ears, perhaps wear headphones or consider popping back later. And I will look forward to catching up with you after this chat with Steve Philip. Hi, welcome along to the podcast, Steve. Hi, Marianne. Really good to be here. Thank you for inviting me. Oh, I feel so honoured that you've agreed. I feel like I've followed you and your work
九月份的话题。你可能在几个月甚至几年后才发现这期节目。这当然是一期非常有力量的节目，因为我们谈论的是自杀。这可能会引发负面情绪，所以请务必照顾好自己。如果你身边有年幼的孩子，请戴上耳机，或者考虑稍后再听。我很期待在与史蒂夫·菲利普的谈话结束后与你交流。你好，欢迎来到播客，史蒂夫。你好，玛丽安。很高兴来到这里。谢谢你的邀请。哦，你答应来参加，我感到非常荣幸。我觉得我关注你和你的工作
for as long as I've been kind of on socials, really. So I can't really imagine a time on LinkedIn when you weren't in it. And so I feel really honoured and privileged that you're affording us your time. No, thank you. And yeah, LinkedIn is a platform I'm very familiar with because it was my career before losing my son, Jordan. I taught organisations about how to use the platform and other social media. So it's somewhere that people have known me for many years, but in two very different stories, really. Absolutely. Well, that partly explains why you are so engaging on LinkedIn and why you've developed the following you have. But of course, it's the very poignant and powerful content that you are discussing, which really is scroll stopping for all the right reasons. Could you tell us a little bit about your son, Jordan, please, Steve? Yes, well, you know, the story or the second story,
只要我还在社交媒体上活跃，我就一直关注着你。所以我无法想象在领英上没有你的日子。因此，你能抽出时间来参加我们的节目，我感到非常荣幸。不，谢谢你。是的，领英是我非常熟悉的平台，因为在我失去儿子乔丹之前，这就是我的职业。我曾教导各机构如何使用该平台和其他社交媒体。所以，人们认识我已经很多年了，但实际上是在两个截然不同的故事中认识我的。确实如此。嗯，这在一定程度上解释了为什么你在领英上如此引人入胜，以及为什么你拥有现在的粉丝群。当然，你所讨论的内容非常深刻且有力，确实让人忍不住停下来阅读，而且理由非常充分。史蒂夫，你能给我们讲讲你的儿子乔丹吗？好的，你知道，这个故事，或者说第二个故事，
as you were, Marion started on December the 4th of 2019, when Jordan was 34 at the time, took his own life, something that none of us had expected, despite the fact that he was diagnosed four and a half years prior to that with clinical anxiety and depression. I think it's fair to say that most of us who knew Jordan were uneducated about the risks involved. So when it did happen, it was a complete shock. For context, Jordan's story is not that dissimilar to many others that I've that I've heard say he was 34 at the time he had his own house um just outside Leeds he had a successful career as a officer with the Independent Office for Police Conduct the IOPC quite a stressful job but managing it well very well thought of he had a
正如你所说，玛丽恩，故事始于2019年12月4日。当时乔丹34岁，他选择了结束自己的生命。这是我们所有人都没预料到的，尽管事实上他在四年前就被诊断出患有临床焦虑症和抑郁症。我认为可以公平地说，我们大多数认识乔丹的人对所涉及的风险都缺乏了解。所以当这件事发生时，这完全是一个打击。为了说明背景，乔丹的故事与我听到的许多其他人的故事并没有太大不同。他当时34岁，在利兹郊外有自己的房子，在独立警察行为办公室（IOPC）担任官员，事业有成。那是一份压力很大的工作，但他处理得很好，大家对他的评价也非常高，他有
lovely relationship with his partner Charlotte a loving family despite his mother and I having separated and divorced back in 2005 we've kept a very close relationship she's best friends with Jordan's step-mom which which is wonderful thing to see-year-old mother finds it a little weird when the three of us are sitting on a sofa together, but she's from a different generation maybe. But he was the lad described by his friends as the, you know, the guy who would light up the room when he walked into it. He was over six feet tall, a good-looking lad by most people's estimation.
一段美好的恋情，他的伴侣是夏洛特，还有一个充满爱的家庭。尽管我和他母亲在2005年就分居并离婚了，但我们一直保持着非常亲密的关系。她和乔丹的继母是最好的朋友，这真是太棒了。虽然他20多岁的母亲觉得我们三个人坐在沙发上有点奇怪，但这可能是因为她属于不同的一代。但他被朋友们描述为那种走进房间就能点亮整个空间的人。他身高超过六英尺，在大多数人看来，他是个帅小伙。
His dance moves apparently at weddings and events were legendary. And on many a night out, his friends would look around to see where Jordan was, only to find him in the middle of Leeds, kneeling down, talking to a busker or a homeless person. And Jordan was very much one for the underdog. You know, if he had a friend or a pal that was in trouble. He was probably the first of the group to jump in his car and drive a few hundred miles to be there to support them. And that was very much how Jordan was described to me, really, after his death. Because when you have a child, you know that child until they leave home. And then there's parts of that person's life that you just don't know about, partially because they
他在婚礼和活动上的舞姿显然是传奇般的。在许多夜晚外出时，他的朋友们会环顾四周寻找乔丹，结果却发现他正跪在利兹市中心，与街头艺人或无家可归者交谈。乔丹非常同情弱者。你知道，如果他的朋友或伙伴遇到麻烦，他可能是小组中第一个跳上车，开几百英里去支持他们的人。这就是乔丹去世后人们向我描述的乔丹。因为当你有一个孩子时，你了解那个孩子直到他们离开家。然后，那个人的生活中会有一些你根本不知道的部分，部分原因是他们
keep that very private from their parents and family and partially because they're living a whole different life and existence outside of that direct family circle. But yeah, a lad that I think most parents would be very proud to call their son. It's certain that it shines out of you and the content that you create, really. Just what a lovely, kind person he was. And I feel like I know him, despite the fact that obviously I've never had a chance
对父母和家人保持高度隐私，部分原因是他们在那个直接的家庭圈子之外过着完全不同的生活和存在。但是的，我认为大多数父母都会非常自豪地称他为儿子的那种小伙子。确实，这从你身上和你创作的内容中闪耀出来，他真的是一个可爱、善良的人。我觉得我认识他，尽管显然我从来没有机会
to actually meet him. And the other day I know him despite the fact that obviously I've never had a chance to actually meet him. And the other day I was on holiday in Greece and in the resort was someone I thought was Jordan, because someone looked so like him. And I'm sure you've had moments like that yourself over the years as well, where you, you know, someone's similar posture and size and mannerisms. It was only a few months ago we took a holiday at the end of December, actually, and went to Tenerife, a spot we know well there, just to take a short break before Christmas.
真正见过他。前几天，我在希腊度假，在度假村里有一个人，我以为是乔丹，因为那个人看起来太像他了。我相信这些年来你也有过这样的时刻，你知道，某人的姿势、体型和举止都很相似。就在几个月前，实际上是在12月底，我们去度假，去了特内里费岛，那是我们很熟悉的地方，只是在圣诞节前去短假。
And on a table next to us were some young people. And I remember taking a very sneaky sort of sideways photograph, as I said to my wife, look how much that lad kind of looks like Jordan, and shared it with with the family and and there was a similarity but yeah moments like that kind of stop you in your tracks really they do and for a moment you can kind of imagine or just enjoy seeing them I think this is the power of video content as well isn't it that you can see them alive and well and yeah sort of you kind of kind of it's it's a mixed poignant emotions isn't it so you know bittersweet happiness oh yeah definitely
在我们旁边的桌子上坐着一些年轻人。我记得我偷偷地从侧面拍了一张照片，正如我对妻子所说，看那个小伙子长得有多像乔丹，并与家人分享了它。确实有相似之处，但这种时刻真的会让你停下脚步。它们确实会，有一瞬间你可以想象或只是享受看到他们。我认为这就是视频内容的力量，不是吗？你可以看到他们活生生的样子，是的，这是一种混合的、深刻的情感，不是吗？所以你知道，苦乐参半的幸福。哦，是的，绝对是。
um just before we came on air you talked about the fact that um uh say Jordan's stepmom and I married 10 years ago uh this this month and um as part of that day, we treated ourselves to a spa day locally, but we pulled out the wedding video that was really nicely produced by somebody locally for us. But, of course, as we sat there and watched it, there was Jordan delivering his little poem and nervous as heck delivering it and other moments where we could see him during the video. So, you know, we both said it was a
嗯，在我们直播之前，你谈到了这样一个事实，嗯，乔丹的继母和我十年前的这个月结婚了。作为那一天的一部分，我们在当地享受了一次水疗日，但我们拿出了由当地人精心制作的婚礼视频。当然，当我们坐在那里观看时，乔丹正在朗诵他的小诗，朗诵时紧张得要命，还有其他时刻我们可以在视频中看到他。所以，你知道，我们俩都说这是一个
real roller coaster you know such a happy day and yet on reflection now you look back and go wow you know there's all that potential still there you know 10 years ago absolutely um i'm pleased you've got those memories and that you've got them to be able to look back on but i just i wish it had a different outcome. And the audience for this video in this podcast episode will be varied. Actually, we may have people listening or watching because they've recently been affected by suicide or because they're starting to worry about themselves or someone they care about. about you know the question that we often might ask in a mental health service along the lines of are you having thoughts that life might not be worth living or have you had any thoughts about about ending your own life or or planning or preparing for that and sometimes a parent will
真正的过山车，你知道，如此快乐的一天，但现在回想起来，你会感叹，哇，你知道，十年前还有那么多的潜力。绝对的。嗯，我很高兴你有那些记忆，并且能够回首往事，但我只是希望它有一个不同的结果。这个视频和播客剧集的受众将会是多种多样的。实际上，我们可能有听众或观众是因为他们最近受到自杀的影响，或者因为他们开始担心自己或他们关心的人。关于你知道我们在心理健康服务中经常问的问题，比如你是否有生活可能不值得继续下去的想法，或者你是否有过结束自己生命的想法，或者计划或准备这样做。有时父母会
become aware of that answer before a service will and it's it's how to manage that but some other audience will be people working in mental health services who'll be having these clients in the room with them or or their referrals on their desk almost as we as we speak as they're listening to this and it's it's a big deal and we want we want to get it right for everybody that's listening and everybody that's watching and everyone that comes into contact with these people it's a really really big but important job isn't it so I guess if we first speak to what the heck do we do if we find ourselves in this position how can we try not to scare people away and that would be the same as a parent or someone working in a service how can we
在服务机构意识到之前就意识到这个答案，这是如何管理的问题。但其他受众将是心理健康服务的工作人员，他们会在房间里接待这些客户，或者在他们说话时，在他们听这个节目时，他们的转诊单就在桌子上。这是一件大事，我们想为每一位听众、每一位观众以及每一位与这些人接触的人做好这件事。这是一项非常非常大但重要的工作，不是吗？所以我想，如果我们首先谈谈如果我们发现自己处于这种境地该怎么办，我们如何尽量不去吓跑人们，这对父母或在服务机构工作的人来说是一样的，我们如何
how can we have this powerful impact yeah it's a really good question marion and you know we hear the word normalize used a lot how do we normalize the conversation around mental health how do we normalize the conversation around suicide? But because it is so prevalent, because it impacts so many people in this country alone, you know, over 800,000 people every year are going to be impacted by a suicide death. So we need to recognize the scale of the issue and we need to become more comfortable in talking about a subject that's been extremely taboo. You know, if you had a child or someone you loved who'd gone out on a motorbike, for example, and, you know, they've been riding it too fast, they came off and had an accident but but fortunately got away reasonably unscathed you'd be you know even before that you'd be having a conversation with them wouldn't you
我们如何产生这种强大的影响？是的，这是一个非常好的问题，玛丽恩。你知道，我们经常听到“正常化”这个词，我们如何使围绕心理健康的对话正常化？我们如何使围绕自杀的对话正常化？但因为它太普遍了，因为它仅在这个国家就影响了这么多人，你知道，每年有超过80万人会受到自杀死亡的影响。所以我们需要认识到这个问题的规模，我们需要在谈论一个极其禁忌的话题时变得更加自在。你知道，如果你有一个孩子或你爱的人骑摩托车出去，例如，你知道，他们骑得太快，摔倒并发生了事故，但幸运的是，他们相对安然无恙，你会，你知道，甚至在那之前，你就会和他们交谈，不是吗？
about you know just be careful out there you know these are the risks you know you wouldn't think twice about doing it but but when it comes to to suicide um we we just find it very difficult to have that conversation. So in some way, we have to become better at that. And I think that becomes more of a hope if we, as a society, become a much better educated society around suicide and these conversations are taking place in our workplaces, our schools, in our public health departments and in our communities. Yeah, absolutely.
关于，你知道，在外面要小心，你知道这些是风险，你不会三思而后行。但当谈到自杀时，嗯，我们只是觉得很难进行那种对话。所以，在某种程度上，我们必须在这方面做得更好。我认为，如果我们作为一个社会，在自杀方面成为一个受过更好教育的社会，并且这些对话在我们的工作场所、学校、公共卫生部门和社区中进行，那么这就会成为更多的希望。是的，绝对是。
And it's kind of evoking memories of when I worked in a CAMHS service, which is, for anyone who's not sure, it's the service for children, adolescents with mental health difficulties. And as part of that, there'll be close working with families. And sometimes a parent would be realising that their child is self-harming and then naturally sort of jump to the conclusion that that means that they're suicidal. And to that, I would say not always. Sometimes people will engage in acts of self-harm, but never become suicidal. And so the two are separate.
这让我想起了我在儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）工作时的记忆，对于那些不确定的人来说，这是为有心理健康困难的儿童和青少年提供的服务。作为其中的一部分，会有与家庭的密切合作。有时父母会意识到他们的孩子在自残，然后自然而然地得出结论，这意味着他们有自杀倾向。对此，我会说并不总是这样。有时人们会进行自残行为，但从不产生自杀倾向。所以两者是分开的。
But of course, what we know is it's possible for people to engage in no self-harm but be suicidal or actually end their own life. And it's a lot, isn't it? It is. And I think if we look at, again, young people in particular, what are the risks involved? You know, things have changed, particularly from my day as a young person, that I think the pressures,
但当然，我们知道人们有可能不进行自残却有自杀倾向，或者实际上结束了自己的生命。这很多，不是吗？确实。我认为如果我们再次审视年轻人，特别是涉及的风险是什么？你知道，事情已经改变了，特别是从我年轻的时候开始，我认为压力，
societal pressures on young people are far more multifaceted and extreme than we ever experienced. You know, the worst-case scenario for us was our parents were probably worried if we'd fall out of a tree because we were climbing it. But, you know, we've got, you know, peer pressure at a level we've never seen before. A lot of that through online social media comparisons and influences out there at the moment. We've got standards within schools that are having a knock on effect not not only to teaching staff but to the pupils as well it seems to be almost now from preschool there's a standard you've got to meet as a young
年轻人面临的社会压力比我们经历的要复杂和极端得多。你知道，对我们来说最坏的情况是，如果我们在爬树时摔下来，我们的父母可能会担心。但是，你知道，我们有前所未有的同伴压力。其中很多是通过在线社交媒体的比较和目前的影响者。我们在学校里有标准，这不仅对教学人员，而且对学生也产生了连锁反应。现在似乎几乎从学前班开始，作为一个年轻人，你必须达到一个标准，
person or an examination you've got to to go through we're in a world that many are considering is unstable in many respects from a from a climate point of view and some of the conflicts we're seeing around the world. So, you know, there are many reasons why young people in particular are feeling confused, displaced and fearful for the future. And if we know and understand that, although there are many reasons why someone might go down the path of attempting suicide, two things usually create that situation. One is a sense that that person is trapped in some way.
或者你必须通过考试。我们生活在一个许多人认为在许多方面不稳定的世界里，从气候的角度来看，以及我们在世界各地看到的一些冲突。所以，你知道，年轻人特别是感到困惑、流离失所和对未来感到恐惧是有很多原因的。如果我们知道并理解这一点，尽管一个人走上自杀未遂道路的原因有很多，但通常有两件事会造成这种情况。一是那个人在某种程度上被困住了的感觉。
That can be in a relationship or in financial difficulties or through addictions or whatever it might be, which ultimately leads to a sense of hopelessness. And if that person feels hopeless about the future in any way, then that's the point where they've now potentially become at risk of considering suicide. So I, again, yeah, hope I was really thinking about the timeframe of Jordan's death at the latter end of 2019. And, of course, what we know came next was the pandemic and I'm kind of struck by the fact that I'm remembering that Caroline Flack
这可能是在一段关系中，或在经济困难中，或通过成瘾，或任何可能的情况，这最终导致了一种绝望感。如果那个人对未来感到绝望，那么这就是他们现在可能面临自杀风险的点。所以我，再次，是的，希望我真的在思考乔丹在2019年底去世的时间框架。当然，我们知道接下来发生的是大流行，我被这样一个事实所震撼，我记得卡罗琳·弗拉克（Caroline Flack）
ended her own life in February Valentine's Day wasn't it 2020 but what we know with hindsight is that just a couple of weeks after that, everything seemed to stop mattering. And the kind of context of the entire world shifted and nobody could have known what was going to happen with the pandemic. But it may have made such a difference to so many people in terms of everything shifting online, people staying home, the pressures being different, people may have been furloughed. You know, people are not, shame almost would have been excised from so many situations and guilt and responsibility and shoulds and I musts.
在2020年2月情人节那天结束了自己的生命，不是吗？但我们事后知道的是，在那之后仅仅几周，一切似乎都不再重要了。整个世界的背景发生了转变，没有人能预料到大流行会发生什么。但这可能对许多人产生了如此大的影响，因为一切都转移到了网上，人们呆在家里，压力变得不同，人们可能被休假了。你知道，人们不是，羞耻感几乎从许多情况中被剔除，还有内疚、责任、“应该”和“我必须”。
And that's the variable that we just, we can't account for and we can't turn back time. Nobody could have known that was going to happen but I find myself as a professional dwelling on that because so many people did seem to begin to thrive on the other side of the pandemic where actually they'd shifted to working from home or remotely or they'd they'd seen that actually nothing happens if they don't go to work every day you know and they are happier and actually when they include exercise and they've got more time to eat and they're not spending an hour each way commuting they're able to spend time with their
这就是我们无法解释的变量，我们无法让时光倒流。没有人能预料到会发生这种情况，但我发现自己作为一名专业人士在思考这个问题，因为在大流行的另一边，许多人似乎开始茁壮成长，实际上他们已经转向在家工作或远程工作，或者他们已经看到，如果他们不每天去上班，实际上什么也不会发生，你知道，他们更快乐，实际上当他们包括锻炼时，他们有更多的时间吃饭，他们不需要花费一个小时的通勤时间，他们能够花时间与他们的
family and their loved ones and it just it's less depleting and more enjoyable and kind of it reminded so many of us about the important factors for life I think I think that's a really important point to make Marion for a number of reasons so you know I think back to those initial weeks and days and weeks following Jordan's suicide um you know where was I in that moment i was in a in a place where nothing mattered really at all you know we talked offline again about the fact that my work with the jordan legacy is full-time and i immediately stepped back from my career in consultancy because that didn't matter um you know nothing in previous to jordan's death would have ever made me make that kind of decision. Yeah, I mean, literally nothing really kind of, nothing could have hurt me, nothing could have
家人和亲人在一起，这只是减少了消耗，增加了乐趣，并且它提醒了我们许多人关于生活的重要因素。我认为这是一个非常重要的观点，玛丽恩，原因有很多。所以，你知道，我回想起乔丹自杀后的最初几周和几天，嗯，你知道，那一刻我在哪里？我处于一个什么都不重要的地方，真的。你知道，我们再次在离线状态下谈论了这样一个事实，即我在乔丹遗产（The Jordan Legacy）的工作是全职的，我立即退出了我的咨询职业，因为那并不重要。你知道，在乔丹去世之前，没有任何事情会让我做出那种决定。是的，我的意思是，真的没有什么，没有什么能伤害我，没有什么能
harmed me, nothing could be worse than what had happened. And I know so many other people bereaved by suicide, you know, have said they felt the same way. And then, as you say, we all moved into COVID at that period of time. And I think there were many who, and we saw the tweets, we saw the comments on social media suggesting that suicides were increasing rapidly as a result of the COVID pandemic. We know that wasn't factual, unusually for X and Twitter. We know, in fact, there was a slight decrease of 5% in suicides during that period. And there's a theory and a belief out there that we changed our attitudes during that period of time that we did, as you say, started to realize that actually lots of things we did worry about before were maybe not as critical, but we also as a community and a society came together.
伤害我，没有什么比发生的事情更糟糕了。我知道许多其他因自杀而丧亲的人，你知道，也说他们有同样的感觉。然后，正如你所说，我们在那个时期都进入了新冠疫情。我认为有许多人，我们看到了推文，我们看到了社交媒体上的评论，暗示由于新冠疫情，自杀率正在迅速增加。我们知道那不是事实，对于X和Twitter来说这很不寻常。我们知道，事实上，在那期间自杀率略有下降5%。并且有一种理论和信念认为，我们在那段时间改变了我们的态度，我们确实，正如你所说，开始意识到实际上我们以前担心的很多事情可能并不那么关键，但我们也作为一个社区和社会走到了一起。
We started looking out for each other. We started doing shopping for our neighbors and checking in with them and family to see if they were OK. We did all these things, which we should be still doing. But as is the human race, we've kind of reverted back to type in many cases. Some haven't. Of course, they've continued on. But it proved that as a society we can be kinder, we can be more supportive of one another, and as a result of that, you know, more people can thrive as a result.
我们开始互相照顾。我们开始为邻居购物，并与他们和家人核对他们是否还好。我们做了所有这些事情，我们应该继续做这些事情。但正如人类一样，我们在许多情况下又回到了老样子。有些人没有。当然，他们继续前行。但这证明了作为一个社会，我们可以更友善，我们可以更支持彼此，结果就是，你知道，更多的人可以因此而茁壮成长。
So I think it's a really important point you make. I think we are definitely stronger together. Like I love people. I love conversations in Tesco about cauliflowers with random people. Like, I really, I really like connecting with people. And I think when we were all masked up, and in many ways, were being more community driven but we were having to be physically distanced from people that I think that was trickier so this is you know it wasn't all hearts and flowers during the pandemic you know especially for someone in a domestically violent relationship where they're suddenly in a lockdown situation with that partner or you know actually what we also recognized during lockdown was that so many of us, we have
所以我认为你提出的观点非常重要。我认为我们在一起确实更强大。就像我喜欢人。我喜欢在乐购（Tesco）里和随机的人谈论花椰菜。就像，我真的，我真的很喜欢与人建立联系。我认为当我们都戴着口罩时，在许多方面，我们更加以社区为导向，但我们不得不与人保持身体距离，我认为这更棘手。所以这是，你知道，在大流行期间并不全是心和花，你知道，特别是对于处于家庭暴力关系中的人，他们突然处于与该伴侣的封锁状态，或者你知道，实际上我们在封锁期间也认识到，我们许多人，我们有
our three soothing systems, I don't know if you've done these three systems, it's compassion and focus therapy idea, so you've got your drive, your threat and your soothe system, so many of us had our soothe system activated outside of the house, so it might have been cinema trips, it might have been meals with parents, it might have been, you know, catching up with friends at the pub or it might have been meals with parents it might have been you know catching up with friends at the pub or it might have been cinema it might have been um I've said cinema twice cinema twice go twice in a week's fine um it might have been gym going you know it might have been something outside of your home that kept you really well and then when all that went off limits it's almost like how do I begin to soothe myself which is why there was kind of suddenly loads more kind of downloads of mindfulness apps and the podcasting went through the roof I don't know if
我们的三个舒缓系统，我不知道你是否做过这三个系统，这是同情心和焦点疗法的想法，所以你有你的驱动、威胁和舒缓系统，我们许多人在房子外面激活了我们的舒缓系统，所以它可能是去电影院，它可能是与父母一起吃饭，它可能是，你知道，在酒吧与朋友聚会，或者它可能是与父母一起吃饭，它可能是，你知道，在酒吧与朋友聚会，或者它可能是电影，它可能是，嗯，我说过两次电影，两次电影，一周去两次没关系，嗯，它可能是去健身房，你知道，它可能是你家外面让你保持非常健康的东西，然后当所有这些都受到限制时，就像我如何开始舒缓自己，这就是为什么突然有更多下载正念应用程序的原因，播客也火爆了，我不知道你是否
you're part of the clubhouse generation but clubhouse was like a just exploded because everyone was home and listening to that and so really encouraged us to think about how we soothe ourselves and how we keep ourselves well and obviously a part of this time you were thinking about this needs to be different this needs to matter you know there needs to be a purpose and so you began to think about Jordan Legacy coming coming to fruition and obviously that's happened. Could you tell us a little bit about the project, the company and what you what your aims are? Yeah, it's it was an interesting time because like many people bereaved by suicide, your your instant reaction once the dust has settled, so to speak, is is right.
你是Clubhouse一代的一部分，但Clubhouse就像爆炸了一样，因为每个人都在家听那个，所以真的鼓励我们思考我们如何舒缓自己以及我们如何保持健康。显然，在这段时间的一部分，你在想这需要不同，这需要重要，你知道，需要有一个目的，所以你开始考虑乔丹遗产（Jordan Legacy）的实现，显然这已经发生了。你能告诉我们一点关于这个项目、公司以及你的目标是什么吗？是的，这是一个有趣的时期，因为像许多因自杀而丧亲的人一样，一旦尘埃落定，你的即时反应，可以说，是正确的。
What do I do now with my life? And think because um I was so uneducated about this this subject and started to realize that that many other people were as well um I wanted to get the message out there so people understood the the risks and that all began only three weeks after Jordan's death when I went back to LinkedIn a platform I knew well, and in some way as a release to get some anger out, I shared my story as an article. And partially in the hope as well that if I explained how awful this situation was that we were going through, that it might just resonate with somebody who was thinking of taking their own life. And it might just cause them to go go let me just step back from this and although it was a naive thought and I recognized that that that it doesn't work quite as easy as that it did in fact work because I did get many messages from people who said I've read your article I just can't do this to my family
我现在的生活该怎么办？我想因为嗯，我对这个主题太缺乏教育了，并开始意识到许多其他人也是如此，嗯，我想把信息传达出去，这样人们就能理解风险。这一切都始于乔丹去世仅三周后，当我回到领英时，这是一个我非常熟悉的平台，在某种程度上作为一种释放愤怒的方式，我把我的故事写成了一篇文章分享了。部分原因也是希望如果我解释了我们正在经历的这种情况有多糟糕，它可能会引起某个正在考虑结束自己生命的人的共鸣。它可能只是导致他们去，让我从这件事中退后一步。虽然这是一个天真的想法，我承认它没有那么容易，但它确实奏效了，因为我确实收到了许多人的信息，他们说我读了你的文章，我不能对我家人这样做
and I thank you for sharing it and and the article, as far as LinkedIn is concerned, went viral. I had people like Ariana Huffington from the HuffPost emailing me and lots of people. And I think although I knew I had a voice on that platform, I suddenly realized that potentially I had a new voice and that people, if they could resonate with what I'd written there, that perhaps if I shared more of the story and, you know, that might in turn help me spread a message.
我感谢你分享它。就领英而言，这篇文章疯传了。我有像赫芬顿邮报（HuffPost）的阿里安娜·赫芬顿（Arianna Huffington）这样的人给我发电子邮件，还有很多人。我认为虽然我知道我在那个平台上有一个声音，但我突然意识到我可能有一个新的声音，如果人们能与我在那里写的内容产生共鸣，那么也许如果我分享更多的故事，你知道，这反过来可能会帮助我传播一个信息。
And that message became fairly clear within a number of months when I started talking with a number of people really about what do I do in terms of suicide prevention? What do I need to know? So I was reading books during this time through the whole sort of January to probably late summer of 2020 through that COVID period, watching videos, listening to podcasts, connecting and engaging with people around suicide prevention, not least the many people that reached out to me as a result of some of those early articles and posts.
那个信息在几个月内变得相当清晰，当时我开始与一些人谈论关于自杀预防我该做什么？我需要知道什么？所以我在这段时间里，从2020年1月到大概夏末的整个新冠疫情期间，一直在读书，看视频，听播客，与周围的人联系和互动，进行自杀预防，尤其是那些因为我早期的一些文章和帖子而联系我的人。
And it became very clear that I wasn't going to set up a charity that was going to be a helpline or, you know, they were there. They were already there. I didn't want to just go out and do fundraising or anything like that. I wanted to know what were the practical things that needed to be done. And as I started to learn more about the zero suicide community globally and society and the practical solutions that could be put in place in our community schools and workplaces and our healthcare systems, that kind of appealed to me because I had a business background. That kind of made sense. What can we do in a practical way? So the Jordan legacy, its mission has always been to help us move towards a zero suicide society. That term often gets some pushback, but it's an evidence-based concept that comes out of Detroit and the healthcare system through the Henry Ford healthcare system there in the early 2000s. But it,
很明显，我不会建立一个慈善机构，那将是一个求助热线，或者，你知道，它们就在那里。它们已经存在了。我不想只是出去做筹款或类似的事情。我想知道需要做哪些实际的事情。当我开始更多地了解全球零自杀社区和社会，以及可以在我们的社区学校、工作场所和医疗系统中实施的实际解决方案时，这对我很有吸引力，因为我有商业背景。这很有道理。我们能以实际的方式做什么？所以乔丹遗产（The Jordan Legacy），它的使命一直是帮助我们走向零自杀社会。这个术语经常受到一些阻力，但它是一个基于证据的概念，源于底特律和医疗系统，通过2000年代初那里的亨利·福特医疗系统。但是它，
by our definition, is a society that is willing and able to do all it can to prevent all preventable suicides. And the argument is that if we don't aspire to zero, what do we aspire to? Because anything less than that is surely suggesting that we're going to set limitations and restrictions on that. So that's where that comes from. We recognize and the research will. So that's where that comes from. We recognize and the research will support that most suicides are preventable, but not all suicides. And that's a really important message because for anyone who's lost someone
根据我们的定义，是一个愿意并能够尽其所能预防所有可预防自杀的社会。争论点是，如果我们不渴望零，我们渴望什么？因为低于这个水平的任何东西肯定是在暗示我们将对此设置限制和约束。所以这就是它的来源。我们认识到，研究也会。所以这就是它的来源。我们认识到，研究也会支持大多数自杀是可以预防的，但并非所有自杀都是如此。这是一个非常重要的信息，因为对于任何失去亲人的人来说
to suicide like me, to be told that all suicides are preventable, you start looking at yourself. You go, well, so what did I do wrong there? So I think we've got to be really very conscious of that that message and how that is is delivered so our work is to and as we've done so far engage with government departments with other charities with campaigners with people working in local authorities within businesses schools and communities to have the conversation. So I deliver a lot of talks on this subject, but also to to collaborate and work in partnership. And one of our missions really moving forward from autumn of 2024 is recognizing that we've we've had 16 years now of suicide numbers flatlining at best, increasing at worst. And now with the latest Samaritans report that
像我这样有自杀倾向的人，如果被告知所有的自杀都是可以预防的，你就会开始审视自己。你会想，那我到底哪里做错了？所以我认为我们必须非常清醒地意识到这种信息以及它是如何传递的。因此，我们的工作是——正如我们迄今为止所做的那样——与政府部门、其他慈善机构、活动家、地方当局的工作人员、企业、学校和社区进行接触，展开对话。我经常就这个主题发表演讲，同时也致力于合作与建立伙伴关系。我们从2024年秋季开始的一个真正使命是认识到，过去16年来，自杀人数在最好的情况下持平，在最坏的情况下还在增加。而现在，根据撒玛利亚会（Samaritans）的最新报告，
came out a few months ago, we now know we've seen a 6% increase in suicides during 2022 and 2023. That's 5% for men and 8% for women. So something's not working. National suicide prevention strategies are not delivering the significant downturn that we need to see. So one of our major focuses going forward is how can we bring all these incredible people together that are doing marvelous work in pockets around the country? How do we bring us all together to share that knowledge and experience? Let go of the egos sometimes that hold us back i think as a community how can we all come together to really make that massive macro difference that needs to happen so that we don't see a figure of 6 000 plus deaths by suicide every year in this country that that we do steadily
几个月前发布的报告显示，2022年和2023年期间，自杀人数增加了6%。其中男性增加了5%，女性增加了8%。所以，有些方法行不通。国家自杀预防策略并没有带来我们所需要的显著下降。因此，我们未来的主要重点之一是：如何将全国各地在各个领域从事出色工作的杰出人士聚集在一起？我们如何将大家团结起来，分享知识和经验？我认为作为一个群体，我们需要放下有时阻碍我们前进的自负。我们如何才能齐心协力，真正实现所需的宏观层面的巨大改变，从而不再看到这个国家每年有6000多人死于自杀，而是看到这个数字稳步
start to see coming down to five and four and moving closer towards zero. So this is very much our focus. And just one final point on that, Marion, a lot of this thinking came from an action research project and report that the Jordan Legacy published in 2023, which we put together in collaborative partnership with Paul Vittles, who now has his own moving new CIC called Towards Zero Suicide. And that was considered a groundbreaking report by a number of suicide prevention leads in the country.
开始下降到五千、四千，并逐渐趋近于零。这就是我们的重点所在。关于这一点，最后补充一点，玛丽恩，很多这种思考源于“乔丹遗产”（The Jordan Legacy）在2023年发布的一项行动研究项目和报告。该报告是我们与保罗·维特尔斯（Paul Vittles）合作完成的，他现在拥有自己令人感动的社会利益公司（CIC），名为“迈向零自杀”（Towards Zero Suicide）。该报告被国内许多自杀预防负责人视为开创性的报告。
And we asked two fundamental questions of dozens of people. Do you believe we can significantly reduce the numbers of suicides in the UK? And if the answer to that question was yes, how far do you think we can significantly reduce the numbers of suicides in the UK? And if the answer to that question was yes, how far do you think we can go? And we looked at all aspects of society and community and workplaces. And essentially what that report did was map out what life would be like if we were living in a zero suicide society. So it's on the basis of that report that we're now moving forward to look at how we can strengthen collaboration in the uk yeah thank you steve you obviously really know
我们向几十个人提出了两个基本问题：你认为我们能显著减少英国的自杀人数吗？如果答案是肯定的，你认为我们能将自杀人数减少到什么程度？我们审视了社会、社区和工作场所的各个方面。本质上，那份报告描绘了如果我们生活在一个“零自杀社会”中，生活会是什么样子。正是基于这份报告，我们现在正在推进如何加强英国境内的合作。是的，谢谢你，史蒂夫，你显然非常了解
your stuff but you're also contributing to the data yourself as part of the jordan legacy and um you know just i hope it really it achieves and strives for its goals. And thinking about that word ego, you know, I'm thinking about myself as a mental health professional. I just want to say to you as a father, every time I hear of somebody's suicide, I'm gutted. Absolutely gutted you know I've spent years in theory and in practice working with people to to strive for this zero suicide alliance but also I'm sure as you have recently had people saying to you if it wasn't for you I would have ended my life and I've heard that on a number of occasions but it almost begins to make you feel slightly slightly powerful and magical for this ability to make a difference and so when I and my colleagues I think I speak for us here of these suicides honestly I cry like if only there'd been a chance for somebody to work with that person but what we
你的专业领域，但作为“乔丹遗产”的一部分，你也在为数据做出贡献。你知道，我真的希望它能实现并努力达成目标。想到“自负”这个词，作为一名心理健康专业人士，我想到我自己。作为一名父亲，我想对你说，每次听到有人自杀，我都感到非常痛苦。真的非常痛苦。你知道，我多年来在理论和实践中与人们一起努力，争取实现这个“零自杀联盟”。但我相信你也一样，最近有人对你说：“如果不是因为你，我可能已经结束自己的生命了。”我多次听到过这样的话，但这几乎让你开始感到自己有一种稍微有点强大和神奇的能力去做出改变。所以，当我和我的同事们——我想我能代表我们大家——听到这些自杀事件时，我真的会哭。如果当时有人能有机会与那个人一起工作该多好，但我们
also know is that people do end their lives when they are in active therapy and active treatment but they also end their lives before they engage with treatment or the shame of engaging with treatment feels too much or the one that is just honestly on a waiting list with no intervention that still really really gets me because one of the things I was doing was working with the NHS was assessing pretty much most of the people in the service so I was holding these stories they weren't just names for me they were people you know with families with lives with goals with with hopes with dreams but also then seeing them on a waiting list that was really really really hard really hard and wanting to create a modern service where actually you get treatment at the point
也知道，人们在接受积极治疗和护理时会结束生命，但他们也会在接受治疗之前，或者因为接受治疗带来的羞耻感太重而结束生命。还有一种情况真的让我非常难受，那就是在等待名单上却没有任何干预措施。因为我曾经做过的一件事是与英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）合作，评估服务中几乎所有的人。所以我承载着这些故事，对我来说，他们不仅仅是名字，他们是有家庭、有生活、有目标、有希望、有梦想的人。但看到他们排在等待名单上，真的非常非常困难，非常难受。我希望能创建一个现代化的服务体系，让你在需要的时候就能得到治疗，
where you need it and that there's a zero wait list service which is what I'd been used to when I worked in a cam service which I know sounds radical but we were working in what was called a choice and partnership approach model at the time so it was all closely calibrated and job related that somebody would come along and if they had a need for treatment they'd be they'd leave the clinic with an appointment their next appointment but it seemed pretty much impossible to replicate that in an adult service which destroyed me really because that's how I wanted to be able to work because people matter lives matter and I know there's some rather grisly research that suggests what's lost to society from a suicide,
实现零等待服务。这正是我在儿童和青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）工作时所习惯的。我知道这听起来很激进，但我们当时采用的是所谓的“选择与伙伴关系方法”（Choice and Partnership Approach）模型。一切都经过精确校准，与工作相关，有人来寻求帮助，如果他们需要治疗，他们离开诊所时就会拿到下一次预约的时间。但在成人服务中复制这一点似乎几乎是不可能的，这真的让我崩溃，因为这就是我想要的工作方式。因为人很重要，生命很重要。我知道有一些相当可怕的研究表明，社会因自杀而损失了什么，
that it's actually there's a monetary value based on what that person would have spent, how they would have populated, how they would have, you know, earned, how the taxing would have happened. There's a big loss to society, to the world, with each and every suicide you know this is something i recently well earlier this year delivered a ted talk at bristol
实际上，基于那个人本可以消费的金额、他们本可以繁衍的后代、他们本可以赚取的收入以及本可以缴纳的税款，这存在着货币价值。每一次自杀对社会、对世界都是巨大的损失。你知道，这是我最近，也就是今年早些时候在布里斯托尔发表TED演讲时提到的内容。
university and it was one of the the points that i that i raised and and and i know it does sound crass because we're talking as you say about lives and and lost opportunities and loved ones but but this is what frustrates me sometimes about the lack of investment in suicide prevention because when Samaritans brought out their report a few months ago where they estimated that each death by suicide had a cost to the UK economy of £1.45 million, there was the initial cost of death and all that's involved there,
大学，这是我提出的观点之一。我知道这听起来很冷酷，因为正如你所说，我们谈论的是生命、失去的机会和亲人，但这就是有时让我感到沮丧的地方——自杀预防投入的匮乏。因为几个月前“撒玛利亚人”组织发布报告估计，每一起自杀死亡给英国经济造成的损失为145万英镑，这包括了最初的死亡成本以及所有相关费用，
the inquests, of course, and other legal aspects of that. There's the therapy and support, of course, for those that are left behind and ongoing support for them. But there is this loss of earning, depending on the life expectancy of that individual, that's calibrated to be an average of 1.45 million pounds. So if you take the total number of deaths in the UK at over 6,000 to suicide, that's what's reported, you're looking at a staggering 10 billion pounds in cost to the UK economy. Surely it makes sense to invest that money up front in just the same way as it makes sense from a physical health point of view to have a preventative program in place to stop people being ill. But we just don't seem to get either of those right in society at all but it just seems a no-brainer to a layman like me it really does like it's just simple economics really absolutely totally agree so how how do we you know if we've got that six billion then he goes he goes steve is six billion
当然还有死因裁判官的调查以及其他法律方面的事宜。当然，还有为逝者家属提供的治疗和支持，以及对他们的持续支持。但还有收入损失，根据个人的预期寿命，这被校准为平均145万英镑。因此，如果你把英国每年超过6000起的自杀死亡总数（这是报告的数据）加起来，你会看到一个惊人的数字：给英国经济造成了100亿英镑的损失。如果从身体健康的角度来看，建立预防计划以防止人们生病是有意义的，那么预先投入这笔钱肯定也是有意义的。但我们似乎在社会中根本没有做好这两件事，对于像我这样的外行来说，这简直是不言而喻的，真的，这其实就是简单的经济学。绝对完全同意，那么我们该怎么做呢，如果我们有那60亿，然后他说，他说史蒂夫，是60亿，
how i know it's 10 10 10 billion 10 billion sorry i've short changed you i've kept i've kept four billion under my desk but we'll take this we'll take the six billion though you know because we're not getting that i'm gonna give it you all here you go here's the other four so i'm giving you all 10 billion what what are we doing with it yeah what are we doing with it or what should we be doing with it what do we do with it if we've got 10 billion now how do we create this gold standard get it right first time it might be a service it might be you know just something that takes you from the first realisation that I'm having thoughts, life isn't that enjoyable, to then beginning to live a fully active, enjoyable life? When we published our report in July of 2023,
我知道是100亿，100亿，抱歉，我少算了，我把40亿藏在桌子底下了，但我们还是拿这60亿吧，因为我们拿不到那个，我要把所有的都给你，给你，这是另外40亿，所以我给你全部100亿，我们用它做什么？是的，我们用它做什么，或者我们应该用它做什么？如果我们现在有100亿，我们该怎么做？我们如何创造这个黄金标准，一次性把它做好？它可能是一项服务，也可能只是某种东西，能带你从“我有了这些想法，生活没那么有趣”的最初觉悟，到开始过上完全积极、愉快的生活？当我们于2023年7月发布报告时，
we took the 84 pages of that report that Paul and I had worked on and thought, how do we condense this visually? And we created this jigsaw puzzle, if you like, where all the pieces slot together. And they were all the aspects of suicide prevention that if practical solutions were implemented and they all came together, you know, would make that difference. And this is what we were told by all those people
我们拿出了保罗和我共同完成的那份84页的报告，心想，我们该如何从视觉上浓缩它呢？于是我们创造了这个拼图，如果你愿意的话，所有的碎片都可以拼在一起。它们涵盖了自杀预防的所有方面，如果能实施切实可行的解决方案，并且它们能结合在一起，你知道，那就会产生影响。这就是所有那些人告诉我们的，
that we interviewed and spoke with, many of them with lived experience. And it's a combination of factors that we need to invest in listening more to those with lived experience and get their involvement and viewpoints. That's really important. We need to look at national suicide prevention strategies that don't prioritise just certain target groups, but recognise that everyone is a priority for someone. We need to have active suicide prevention in our workplaces, in our schools, our education systems, in our health systems. We definitely need a suicide prevention educated and activated public.
我们采访并交谈过的人，其中许多人有亲身经历。我们需要投资的因素有很多，我们需要更多地倾听那些有亲身经历的人，并获得他们的参与和观点。这非常重要。我们需要审视国家自杀预防策略，不要只优先考虑某些目标群体，而要认识到每个人对某人来说都是优先事项。我们需要在工作场所、学校、教育系统和卫生系统中进行积极的自杀预防。我们绝对需要一个受过自杀预防教育并积极参与的公众。
But then if you look at the infrastructures around our societies and communities, we lobbied through a petition to have a National Suicide Prevention Office, a central office independent of government things that you've mentioned there with your CAMHS experience, Marion chronic pain who are at risk of suicide. We need to invest more in our tech, those things that can help identify when somebody is at risk or provide support when they are. And we need to look at our infrastructures, our buildings, our railways, all the environments where people choose to end their own lives and invest in better protection there i mean the list goes on um that 10 billion can be spent um very quickly when you just consider some of those things but some really wonderful places to start in spending that 10 billion um yeah the And, yeah, the idea of making it harder, you know, monitoring our railway bridges better, having better sensors, having more awareness, maybe even having more, you know, I'm aware that I've got a friend who used to be a travel policeman.
但如果你看看我们社会和社区周围的基础设施，我们通过请愿游说建立了一个国家自杀预防办公室，一个独立于政府的中央办公室，正如你提到的你在CAMHS（儿童和青少年心理健康服务）的经历，玛丽恩，还有那些有自杀风险的慢性疼痛患者。我们需要在技术上投入更多，那些能够帮助识别某人何时处于风险之中，或在他们处于风险时提供支持的技术。我们需要审视我们的基础设施、建筑物、铁路，所有人们选择结束自己生命的环境，并投资于更好的保护措施。我的意思是，名单还在继续，当你考虑到其中一些事情时，那100亿很快就会花完，但开始花这100亿确实有一些非常好的地方，是的，而且，是的，让它变得更难的想法，你知道，更好地监控我们的铁路桥梁，拥有更好的传感器，有更多的意识，甚至可能有更多的，你知道，我知道我有一个朋友曾经是交通警察。
That's not the right word, is it? You know what I mean? British transport police, is it? Yeah, like they just scrapped it all, like in my locality. There's no one who will chase after you if they see someone recklessly driving. Like that's not a thing anymore because they're not out and about. It's more that you get called to a site of disturbance. But there's less, you know, this isn't an anti-police movement at all,
那不是正确的词，对吧？你知道我的意思吗？英国交通警察，是吗？是的，就像他们在我当地把这一切都取消了一样。如果他们看到有人鲁莽驾驶，没有人会去追你。这已经不再是常态了，因为他们不在外面巡逻。更多的是你被叫到骚乱现场。但更少，你知道，这根本不是反警察运动，
but there's just no this isn't an anti-police movement at all this but there's just less there's less presence and are we all quite scared to talk to people and and intervene and um i don't know if you're familiar with one of my friends and colleagues dr tara quinn chirillo but um in the in the locality where she works she's um got a project called the conversation starter project that she actually started during lockdown which is in Horsham Park and literally you get together you go along and you go for a walk and you have conversations with strangers but of course over time those strangers become friends and it's facilitated by a qualified counselling psychologist but it's not therapy but what we know is that when we feel like we're part of something and we've got a function and a purpose that can be so powerful yeah very much so and and again one of our
但这根本不是反警察运动，但这只是更少，存在感更少了，我们是否都害怕与人交谈并进行干预？我不知道你是否熟悉我的朋友和同事塔拉·奎因·奇里洛博士，但在她工作的地区，她有一个项目叫“对话启动者项目”，是她在封锁期间开始的，就在霍舍姆公园，你只要去那里，去散步，和陌生人交谈，但当然随着时间的推移，那些陌生人变成了朋友，它由一位合格的咨询心理学家推动，但这不是治疗，但我们知道的是，当我们觉得我们是某件事的一部分，并且我们有功能和目的时，那会非常强大。是的，非常强大，而且再次强调，我们
our visions for this fairly ambitious um collaborative initiative that we're putting together at the moment is that we recognize there are so many people working in suicide prevention in the third sector, non-professional, if you like, that are doing this alone. You know, people like myself, you know, people think because of the presence that we have online and the work that we've done over the last four years, that we're some massive organization. When they hear there's like two or three of us um you know they're shocked i even had a call from someone recently um or a
对这个目前我们正在组建的相当雄心勃勃的协作倡议的愿景之一是，我们认识到有太多人在第三部门从事自杀预防工作，如果你愿意的话，是非专业人士，他们正在独自做这件事。你知道，像我这样的人，你知道，人们因为我们在网上的存在感以及我们在过去四年中所做的工作，认为我们是一个庞大的组织。当他们听说只有两三个人时，你知道他们很震惊，我最近甚至接到了某人的电话，或者一条
message that said you know we'd love to come up and visit your foundation i said well you can come and have a cup of tea in my kitchen if you want uh because that's who we are you know but there are many like me you know that are working quite isolated very often you know doing the best they can to make a difference but but being part of something bigger than that I believe is a way of helping people like myself and others to feel they're part of a community and not just working tirelessly from home to try and make a difference on specific campaigns or projects. Absolutely. And I know from following you on socials that your daughter now works with the Jordan Legacy as well. Yeah, it's been a really important step, I think, for both of us.
信息说，你知道，我们很想去参观你们的基金会，我说，好吧，如果你愿意，你可以来我的厨房喝杯茶，因为这就是我们，你知道，但有很多像我这样的人，你知道，工作非常孤立，通常你知道，尽他们所能去做出改变，但成为比这更大的事物的一部分，我相信是帮助像我这样的人和其他人感到他们是社区的一部分，而不仅仅是在家里不知疲倦地工作，试图在特定的运动或项目上做出改变的一种方式。绝对。而且我知道通过在社交媒体上关注你，你的女儿现在也和乔丹遗产基金会一起工作。是的，我认为这对我们俩来说都是非常重要的一步。
Now three years it'll be coming up that she started working with us and having been a teaching assistant before, no experience of of uh social media or working in a business environment like this and she looks after and does an incredible job with everything that we do online and looking after elements of our website as well um and although she she shies away from the the limelight um even though i'm trying to push her in certain directions now. You know, she does this wonderful job.
快三年了，她开始和我们一起工作，之前做过助教，没有社交媒体或在这样的商业环境中工作的经验，她负责并出色地完成了我们在网上所做的一切，也照顾我们网站的元素，虽然她回避聚光灯，即使我现在正试图把她推向某些方向。你知道，她做得非常出色。
And then every so often she will write a post of her own, very heartfelt post, beautifully written, which resonates with so many people and embarrassingly outshines mine quite easily when she writes them, which is wonderful to see. And, you know, I think one of the things we've both found about this work is, and people have asked me a question quite often, you know, how easy or difficult is it to do what you do? And this conversation I had with Danielle very recently,
然后每隔一段时间，她就会写一篇她自己的帖子，非常真诚的帖子，写得很美，引起了许多人的共鸣，而且令人尴尬的是，当她写这些帖子时，很容易就盖过了我的风头，这真是太棒了。而且，你知道，我认为我们俩在工作中发现的一件事是，人们经常问我一个问题，你知道，做你所做的事情有多容易或多困难？我和丹妮尔最近进行的这次谈话，
you said, how are you finding this? Because, of course, she's sharing images of her brother, sharing stories of her brother. All the conversations are really about her brother whatever it is that we we do and she's felt that loss like we we all have um and she said i don't know she said i suppose when i'm working on the jordan legacy anything i do there it's it's like it's like work it's like a project and a separate box that i put this into. And it's very much what I've had to do as well.
你说，你觉得这怎么样？因为，当然，她正在分享她哥哥的照片，分享她哥哥的故事。所有的谈话其实都是关于她哥哥的，无论我们做什么，她都感受到了那种失去，就像我们所有人一样，她说我不知道，她说我想当我在为乔丹遗产基金会工作时，我所做的任何事情，它就像，它就像工作，它就像一个项目，一个我把它放进去的单独的盒子。这确实是我也必须做的事情。
I know there are times where I speak on podcasts, kind of got through today, fine, or deliver talks where there will always be a wobble and a moment because you're talking about something so personal at times and your mind can't help but go there. But I think that's important as well, because I think the day you lose that connection with why you're doing this and that does happen with some charitable organizations. I think that's the time you step away because you become too disassociated with with what's with what's happened. So I think for both of us, yeah, working together is great. We work remotely remotely she's about 80 miles away from me so she doesn't have to put up with me physically every day uh does a great job and we we both are able to have our private moments and reflection about jordan um but when we we come to each day we're able to sort of crack on and do what we we need to do so I think in some ways it's I wouldn't necessarily call it a therapy but for me I think it has helped enormously to throw
我知道有时我在播客上发言，今天算是顺利度过了，或者发表谈话，总会有动摇和时刻，因为你有时在谈论如此私人的事情，你的思想不禁会往那里想。但我认为这也很重要，因为我认为你失去与你为什么做这件事的联系的那一天，这在一些慈善组织中确实会发生，我认为那是你离开的时候，因为你与发生的事情变得太疏离了。所以我认为对我们俩来说，是的，一起工作很棒。我们远程工作，她离我大约80英里远，所以她不必每天都在身体上忍受我，做得很好，我们俩都能有我们私人的时刻和对乔丹的怀念，但当我们面对每一天时，我们能够继续做我们需要做的事情，所以我认为在某些方面，我未必会称之为治疗，但对我来说，我认为这极大地帮助我投入
myself in into this and by talking about it as much as I do I think it's helped me to process some of that grief as well. Yeah I think what you're nicely demonstrating there is kind of externalizing yourself and externalizing jordan from this it's about him and it's about people who find themselves in a situation that he was in so that we can prevent people finding themselves in a situation that you're in but it's it's yeah it's almost like a separate thing it's not about you and your grief anymore it's kind of it's it's morphed beyond that and um the podcast episode just before this one was about how to progress your career when you're grieving um and both myself and my podcast guests were in tears at points during that because it's so raw and sometimes you will
到这件事中，通过尽可能多地谈论它，我认为这也帮助我处理了一些悲伤。是的，我认为你在这里很好地展示了某种外化你自己和外化乔丹，这是关于他，也是关于那些发现自己处于他那种处境的人，这样我们就可以防止人们发现自己处于你所处的处境，但这确实，它几乎就像一件独立的事情，它不再是关于你和你的悲伤，它已经演变成了超越那一点的东西，而且，就在这一集之前的播客剧集是关于当你悲伤时如何推进你的职业生涯，我和我的播客嘉宾在某些时候都流下了眼泪，因为它是如此原始，有时你会
get more of the authentic person showing up as they're talking about that but you know I guess you've you've managed to progress your career whilst grieving it's okay to do that isn't it it's it's okay to to make money to have earnings while still grieving. The two are not mutually exclusive, as we say. Yeah, and I'm really glad you brought that up because, as you asked earlier before we came on air, I do this 100% of the time now. So I had a career where I was a consultant running my own business and earning quite a nice income and a salary, and I stopped.
得到更多真实的自我展现，当他们谈论那个时，但你知道，我想你已经设法在悲伤的同时推进了你的职业生涯，这样做是可以的，不是吗？在悲伤的同时赚钱、有收入是可以的。正如我们所说，两者并不相互排斥。是的，我很高兴你提到了这一点，因为正如你之前在开播前问的那样，我现在100%的时间都在做这个。所以我曾经有一份职业，我是一名顾问，经营着自己的企业，赚取相当不错的收入和薪水，但我停下来了。
I wasn't at retirement age yet at that stage. No real plans for retirement. I had an exit strategy looking ahead several years for the business, but I needed to earn an income. And so, you know, I'm very open about the fact that this is a business really it's a community interest company but to all intents and purposes a limited company and although most of the income will come through the talks that I deliver and donations that is invested in us to do the work that we do we don't have a building we don't have a
那时我还没到退休年龄。没有真正的退休计划。我有一个针对未来几年的企业退出策略，但我需要赚取收入。所以，你知道，我非常坦诚地表示，这实际上是一项业务，它是一个社区利益公司，但实际上是一个有限公司，虽然大部分收入将通过我发表的演讲和捐款获得，这些捐款被投资于我们以做我们所做的工作，我们没有建筑物，我们没有
direct service that we provide but it is invested in us working the hours that we do we don't have a building we don't have a direct service that we provide but it is invested in us working the hours that we do every single day to do the work and you know that i've described today and i think you know we shouldn't shouldn't shy away from from that we're doing a a job that as is important as any other job that's out there at the moment and we have a roof over our heads that needs to be paid for um despite the fact that uh yes certainly the income from this job is nowhere near the income it was from the previous one yeah absolutely and that's some of the stuff i come up against with kind of providing services for aspiring psychologists as well people are like well shouldn't it be free and it's like well be amazing if it was but my mortgage isn't free and you know they tesco don't give me
我们提供的直接服务，但它被投资于我们工作的时间，我们没有建筑物，我们没有我们提供的直接服务，但它被投资于我们工作的时间，我们每天都在做我今天描述的工作，而且你知道，我们不应该回避这一点，我们正在做一份和目前外面任何其他工作一样重要的工作，我们有屋顶需要支付，尽管事实上，是的，这份工作的收入远不及上一份工作的收入。是的，绝对，这也是我在为有抱负的心理学家提供服务时遇到的一些事情，人们会说，难道不应该是免费的吗？就像，如果它是免费的那就太棒了，但我的抵押贷款不是免费的，而且你知道，乐购不会因为我所做的事情而给我
groceries for for doing what i do you know i'm passionate about doing what i do and doing it well but i also do need to live yeah it's really important and i think a lot of people get that it's very rare i i've ever ever come across an issue with that. But it is important. Yeah. At the end of the day, if all the Marks and Spencers and Tescos of the world said, we think you're doing a wonderful job. Have all your clothes and groceries for free. Then we would do it for free. And the local car dealership said, oh, and here's a car. And Jet 2 said, here's a holiday. Absolutely. We would do it all for free. I mean, that's what happens to the influencers,
杂货，你知道，我热衷于做我所做的事情并把它做好，但我也需要生活。是的，这非常重要，我认为很多人都明白这一点，我很少遇到这方面的问题。但这很重要。是的。归根结底，如果世界上所有的玛莎百货和乐购都说，我们认为你做得非常出色。把你所有的衣服和杂货都免费拿走。那么我们就会免费做。如果当地的汽车经销商说，哦，这是一辆车。捷特航空说，这是一次假期。绝对。我们都会免费做。我的意思是，这就是网红们发生的事情，
but the influencers still charge high fees. So they're getting it all free and they're getting the big bucks. You know, that's what we'll do. As you were speaking earlier, I was thinking about hope and hope can feel tricky because what I know that you've spoken about, I think it was looking at Jordan's Gate, we might think a bit about Jordan's Gate shortly, was you saw a young man who looked at peace is good this is good but what we know clinically in services is almost when somebody has come up slightly from depression and kind of crippling anxiety they almost become slightly riskier actually because it's a fact isn't that like and that that's horrendous because that felt really good for you as a parent,
但网红们仍然收取高额费用。所以他们免费得到了这一切，而且他们还赚了大钱。你知道，这就是我们要做的。当你刚才说话时，我在想希望，希望可能会让人觉得棘手，因为我知道你谈论过，我想是关于乔丹之门，我们可能很快会想一下乔丹之门，你看到一个看起来很平静的年轻人，这很好，这很好，但我们在临床服务中知道的是，几乎当某人从抑郁和严重的焦虑中稍微恢复过来时，他们实际上变得稍微更有风险了，这是一个事实，不是吗？这太可怕了，因为作为父母，这让你感觉很好，
but it was kind of at that point where he was suicidal and you didn't necessarily know. And that's incredibly powerful as a parent, but also for anyone listening to this. Yeah, I mean, you're referring and you referenced Jordan's gate and it's what's become a fairly iconic photograph to many people when Jordan, his stepmother and I took a walk not long after he's first been diagnosed with clinical anxiety and depression.
但这几乎是在他有自杀倾向的时候，而你未必知道。作为父母，这非常强大，但对任何听这个的人来说也是如此。是的，我的意思是，你提到了乔丹之门，对许多人来说，这已经成为一张相当标志性的照片，当时乔丹、他的继母和我去散步，就在他第一次被诊断出患有临床焦虑和抑郁症后不久。
We took a walk in the countryside local to where we lived. We came across this gate. Jordan just sat on the top of this gate, was looking up at the sky, big smile on his face. I thought, well, there's a photograph. First time we'd seen him smile in ages. Little did we know that that would become almost a poster for Jordan. Yeah, told you to be a moment.
我们在我们居住地附近的乡村散步。我们遇到了这扇门。乔丹就坐在门顶上，抬头看着天空，脸上带着灿烂的笑容。我想，好吧，这是一张照片。这是我们很久以来第一次看到他微笑。我们几乎不知道那几乎会成为乔丹的海报。是的，告诉你要成为一个时刻。
Always is. But it has and and because you know little did we know that it wasn't until after his death that we read journals that jordan had written that we found in the attic of his home that only a matter of probably a couple of weeks prior to that date he'd written in his journal that he'd been researching methods of suicide for the first time so you know you just have got to be so careful I think the message that you're putting across there is that when we talk about spotting the signs that someone might be suicidal automatically people will look at the depressive signs, the signs of worry, fear. And when someone's suddenly their spirits are uplifted and they seem to be in a better place,
总是这样。但它确实，而且因为你知道，我们几乎不知道，直到他去世后，我们才读到乔丹写的日记，我们在他家的阁楼里发现的，就在那个日期前大概几周，他在日记中写道，他第一次研究了自杀方法，所以你知道，你必须非常小心，我认为你传达的信息是，当我们谈论发现某人可能有自杀倾向的迹象时，人们会自动寻找抑郁的迹象，担忧、恐惧的迹象。当某人的精神突然振奋，似乎处于更好的状态时，
that's the time everyone breathes a sigh of relief. But we also know clinically that this can be a moment where the person has found peace with their decision to end their own life. And because of that, they have a way out. And naturally, as a result, all the stresses and worries and the anxiety and the pressure that they have will be alleviated and their mood will change. So I think, you know, it's a really important sign that if you've seen any change in behavior in someone
那是每个人都松了一口气的时候。但我们也从临床上知道，这可能是那个人已经对结束自己生命的决定感到平静的时刻。正因为如此，他们有了一条出路。自然地，结果是，他们所有的压力、担忧、焦虑和压力都会减轻，他们的情绪也会改变。所以我认为，你知道，这是一个非常重要的信号，如果你看到某人的行为有任何改变，
where they've had a period of depression and suddenly become very upbeat and and seem to have it all together and it's maybe a you know quite a rapid change but you see this change in behavior that's not the time to sit back that's the time just to keep the focus keep having the conversations and checking in to make sure that they're okay or even to say, look, I've noticed this sudden change in behaviour. You seem really, really well. What's brought that on? And try and get to the bottom of that if possible.
他们经历了一段抑郁期，突然变得非常乐观，似乎一切都处理得很好，这可能是一个相当迅速的变化，但你看到了这种行为的变化，那不是坐视不管的时候，那是保持专注、继续交谈并检查以确保他们没问题的时候，甚至可以说，看，我注意到了这种突然的行为变化。你看起来真的，真的很好。是什么带来了这种变化？如果可能的话，试着弄清楚这一点。
Absolutely, absolutely. And I feel like we could talk for a week and still not do this justice. But what's next for Jordan's legacy well we have say two real real areas of focus one I've alluded to before is is a fairly significant vision and plan to strengthen collaboration between those of us that work in the suicide prevention space nationally been having a number of of uh close-knit conversations with people sharing kind of thoughts and been doing quite a bit of research into how do we create such a community because i think um if i mentioned people collaborating in suicide there
绝对，绝对。我觉得我们可以谈论一个星期，仍然无法公正地对待这一点。但乔丹遗产基金会的下一步是什么？好吧，我们说有两个真正的重点领域，一个我之前提到过，是一个相当重大的愿景和计划，旨在加强我们这些在全国范围内从事自杀预防工作的人之间的合作，一直在与人们进行多次密切的交谈，分享想法，并做了相当多的研究，关于我们如何创造这样一个社区，因为我认为，如果我提到人们在自杀方面进行合作，
will be many say well this is you're not the first to have come up with with this idea but but what i wanted to understand was you know what makes real communities and networks work well globally in different settings maybe to suicide prevention what are some of the reasons why maybe some of those um that have tried to go before haven't uh worked and remain sustainable so be doing a lot of research around that and and now have a framework of a plan that we're going to start communicating very soon within the next few weeks and start extending invitations out to those that I know like and trust if you like within my network who would be interested in exploring this
会有许多人说，好吧，这不是第一个想到这个主意的人，但我想要了解的是，你知道，什么让真正的社区和网络在全球不同环境中运作良好，也许是自杀预防之外的，为什么一些之前尝试过的人没有奏效并保持可持续性的一些原因是什么？所以一直在围绕这一点做很多研究，现在有一个计划框架，我们将在未来几周内开始沟通，并开始向我网络中那些我认识、喜欢和信任的人发出邀请，如果他们有兴趣探索这一点，
further because I think we need to do something different and I do believe that strength in numbers we're stronger together something you said earlier is is really important um and you know when i shared this with danielle we had a conversation recently i said what do you what do you think about this i said we've got a choice here or she said you've got a choice dad you can either put that to one side and just carry on delivering talks and doing stuff fairly local which would make a difference that'd be great or you've got this bigger aspiration that will terrify you and us probably but if you don't give it a go how are you going to feel in five ten years time and she said if it doesn't work the door doesn't achieve what you hoped it's going to achieve it will still be better than having done nothing and at least we've given it a shot and i think that's what life is sometimes
进一步，因为我认为我们需要做一些不同的事情，我确实相信人多力量大，我们在一起更强大，你刚才说的一些事情非常重要，而且，你知道，当我与丹妮尔分享这一点时，我们最近进行了交谈，我说你觉得这个怎么样？我说我们在这里有一个选择，或者她说你有一个选择，爸爸，你可以把那个放在一边，继续发表谈话，做一些相当本地的事情，这会有所作为，那会很棒，或者你有这个更大的愿望，这可能会让你和我们感到害怕，但如果你不尝试一下，五年十年后你会感觉如何？她说，如果它不起作用，门没有实现你希望它实现的目标，它仍然会比什么都不做要好，至少我们尝试过了，我认为这就是生活有时，
isn't it it's about giving it your best shot uh for the right reasons and sometimes you're going to win and sometimes you're going to get a silver or a bronze medal yeah analogy they're given the games are very very recent at the time of recording yeah but you want to give yourself permission to to do it as well yeah i i think it's very easy to go you know for imposter syndrome to kick in isn't it and go who am i to to think that i could pull this off but you know again coming back to the olympics and some of the interviews you know from this summer um of people that that shouldn't have been there for all kinds of reasons or didn't believe they could be there and then
不是吗？这是关于为了正确的理由尽你最大的努力，有时你会赢，有时你会得到银牌或铜牌。是的，类比，在录制时游戏非常非常近。是的，但你也想给自己许可去这样做。是的，我认为很容易去，你知道，让冒名顶替综合症发作，不是吗？然后说，我是谁，竟然认为我能做到这一点？但你知道，再次回到奥运会和一些采访，你知道，从今年夏天开始，你知道，那些因为各种原因不应该在那里，或者不相信他们能去那里的人，然后
came away with medals you know some truly inspiring stories they could have gone you know many of them with mental health issues could have gone I'm not well enough to to take part and step back and yet they they showed up and came away you know with with medals so you know I think we need to be inspired by what we've seen this summer in Paris by so many of our athletes as well yeah but I'm also aware that we've had two relatively high profile suicides by by sports professionals or ex-sports professionals over this summer period as well and I'm also aware that this episode is coming out very close to World Suicide Prevention Day but this isn't a conversation for just one day
带着奖牌离开了，你知道，一些真正鼓舞人心的故事，他们本可以，你知道，他们中的许多人有心理健康问题，本可以去说，我身体不够好，无法参加，然后退后，然而他们出现了，你知道，带着奖牌离开了，所以我认为我们需要受到我们在今年夏天在巴黎看到的我们这么多运动员的启发。是的，但我同时也意识到，在这个夏天，我们也有两起相对高调的自杀事件，由体育专业人士或前体育专业人士所为。而且我也意识到，这一集发布的时间非常接近世界预防自杀日，但这不仅仅是一天的谈话，
is it this is this is something that needs to be woven into the fabric of of everything like you said like from real grassroots levels nurseries you know um you know early years education primary and you know i've been a school governor for a couple of years as well during my career and pastoral care is getting so much better and um the episode that's coming, I think, after this one is about by the founder of Daddy Blackbird. And there's a really, really powerful animation that's been created by Caroline's daughter, actually, that's in the episode talking about actually how harmful
是吗？这是需要编织进一切结构中的东西，就像你说的，从真正的基层，托儿所，你知道，早期教育，小学，而且，你知道，在我的职业生涯中，我也做了几年的学校管理者，牧养关怀正在变得越来越好，而且，你知道，我想在这一集之后即将到来的一集是关于“爸爸黑鸟”的创始人。而且，实际上，卡罗琳的女儿创作了一个非常非常强大的动画，在这一集中谈论实际上有多么有害，
and hurtful the word suicide can be used, if used as a joke or if used as a colloquialism and that we need to be aware of the power of that but also that it can be evocative you know but we need to be able to have those conversations in a in a compassionate helpful way and be prepared to have those conversations not just on one day every year yeah and i think it's really important you again coming back to something you said there marion about woven into kind of the fabric of our society and there are different ways to do that you know people like andy mike and tim who we know well the three dads you know have said that you know
和伤害，“自杀”这个词如果被用作笑话或口语，可能会有多么伤人，我们需要意识到它的力量，但也需要意识到它可能是令人回味的，你知道，但我们需要能够以一种富有同情心、有帮助的方式进行这些对话，并准备好进行这些对话，而不仅仅是在每年的一天。是的，我认为这非常重要，你再次回到你刚才说的一些事情，玛丽恩，关于编织进我们社会的结构中，有不同的方法可以做到这一点，你知道，像安迪、迈克和蒂姆这样我们很了解的人，那三个爸爸，你知道，他们说，
their campaign to have suicide prevention on the school's curriculum is about age appropriate training. You know, I remember being invited out last year in October to deliver talks through the Department of Education in Gibraltar. And I was delivering talks to year 12 and 13s where we talked about suicide. And then I suddenly found myself talking to five and six year olds. That hadn't been in the plan beforehand, by the way. And on the plane, hurriedly putting something together for that talk. Once I got the email about four o'clock that morning, but we were able to talk about being kind.
他们将自杀预防纳入学校课程的运动是关于适合年龄的培训。你知道，我记得去年10月被邀请去直布罗陀，通过教育部发表谈话。我正在向12年级和13年级的学生发表谈话，我们谈论了自杀。然后我突然发现自己在和五六岁的孩子交谈。顺便说一句，那不在之前的计划中。在飞机上，匆忙地为那次谈话准备了一些东西。一旦我在那天早上四点左右收到电子邮件，但我们能够谈论善良。
And how do you feel when someone isn't kind to to you and and so we were able to have a conversation around similar issues but just using different different language so there is a way to deal with the issue at hand in age appropriate ways but we need to start early we need to start dealing with young people's emotions early in life so we're not trying to rescue them when they're drowning in in the river to paraphrase the famous Desmond Tutu quote we need to go upstream and find out why they're falling in in the first place and look after them at that point to stop them falling into the river absolutely and I'm currently wearing a patch on my face and part of me is thinking oh maybe I should write you can talk to me about suicide
当你对某人不好时，你感觉如何？所以我们能够围绕类似的问题进行对话，只是使用了不同的语言，所以有一种方法可以用适合年龄的方式处理手头的问题，但我们需要尽早开始，我们需要尽早开始处理年轻人生活中的情绪，这样我们就不会在他们溺水时试图营救他们，引用著名的德斯蒙德·图图的名言，我们需要向上游走，找出他们为什么首先掉进去，并在那个时候照顾他们，以防止他们掉进河里。绝对，我目前脸上贴着一个贴片，我的一部分在想，哦，也许我应该写，你可以和我谈谈自杀，
on my patch so people know but I'm also remembering that when I'm 43 now and when I was in sixth form I was in year 12 I was part of the magazine. We'd founded a magazine. And on the front page, I think, of our second episode, second edition, if you like, I'd written a feature about teen suicide. And I got my mate to pose with some pills on a desk. And, like, you know, I was having these conversations. I might see if I can dig it out to put it in the YouTube episode. But I'm still banging on about this stuff over 20 years later, but we need to keep banging on about this, don't we? Yeah, it's really important. You know, World Suicide Prevention Day is an
在我的贴片上，这样人们就知道，但我同时也记得，我现在43岁了，当我在六年级时，我在12年级，我是杂志的一部分。我们创办了一本杂志。在封面上，我想，在我们第二期，如果你愿意的话，第二版，我写了一篇关于青少年自杀的专题。我让我的朋友在桌子上摆弄一些药丸。而且，就像，你知道，我正在进行这些对话。我可能会看看我是否能把它挖出来放在YouTube剧集中。但我20多年后还在谈论这些东西，但我们需要继续谈论这个，不是吗？是的，这非常重要。你知道，世界预防自杀日是一个
important reminder for everyone. I think these days are really important. They do, you know, have a significance and relevance. But it's important to recognise that kind of every day should be World Suicide Prevention Day as well. And, you know, I would look to any company or school or community organisation out there who may be thinking of doing something for World Suicide Prevention Day or during this month and say, are thinking of doing something for world suicide prevention day or during this month um and say are you just doing it for this day and this week and this month what are your plans once september's finished um and you know i think that's a really important message
对每个人来说重要的提醒。我认为这些日子非常重要。它们确实，你知道，具有意义和相关性。但重要的是要认识到，每一天也应该是世界预防自杀日。而且，你知道，我会看向任何可能正在考虑为世界预防自杀日或在这个月期间做点什么的任何公司、学校或社区组织，并说，正在考虑为世界预防自杀日或在这个月期间做点什么，并说，你只是为了这一天、这一周和这个月而做吗？九月结束后你的计划是什么？而且，你知道，我认为这是一个非常重要的信息，
to get across yeah and it's safe to use the word suicide it's safe to talk about it you know you're not going to give somebody an idea because if that's not something that they are considering they will they will be you know they will be taken aback with that and that's not something that you're giving them as an idea but being able to have that conversation in a way that feels safe might just be the difference that makes a difference. Oh, that question, we know from so many people who've been asked that question, are you considering suicide or are you thinking about ending your own life, that invariably it's been the question they've been hoping
要传达出来。是的，使用“自杀”这个词是安全的，谈论它是安全的，你知道，你不会给某人一个想法，因为如果这不是他们正在考虑的事情，他们会，你知道，他们会感到惊讶，那不是你给他们的想法，但能够以一种感觉安全的方式进行那种对话，可能正是产生差异的差异。哦，那个问题，我们从许多被问到那个问题的人那里知道，你是否在考虑自杀，或者你是否在考虑结束自己的生命，总是他们一直希望
someone would ask them and it's come as a huge relief and release for them to be able to answer that that question um you know it's a myth that it will plant the seed in someone's mind as you rightly say um and um it's so important you're more likely to save a life than than lose one by asking that question absolutely where can our audience learn more about you and about the jordan legacy i think the website is uh two places i suppose the website and and by connecting or following with me on on uh linkedin where i'll share a lot of fresh regular content and thoughts uh there um the website is the jordanlegacy.com. You'll find our mission and our strategy and all
有人会问他们，能够回答那个问题对他们来说是一种巨大的解脱和释放，你知道，这是一种神话，它会在某人的脑海中种下种子，正如你正确说的那样，而且，这太重要了，通过问那个问题，你更有可能挽救生命，而不是失去生命。绝对，我们的听众可以在哪里了解更多关于你和乔丹遗产基金会的信息？我想网站是，我想是两个地方，网站，以及通过在LinkedIn上与我联系或关注我，我会在那里分享很多新鲜的定期内容和想法，网站是thejordanlegacy.com。你会发现我们的使命和我们的战略以及所有
about us and Jordan's story on there as well. So that'll give you a real feel for the work you do, we do, I should say. But also, you know, if anyone would like to support our work, we've got a menu there that says supporting us. and you can see our fundraisers what other people have done from running marathons to climbing mountains doing all kinds of things to support us and without that support um you know we wouldn't be able to continue doing the work that we do so whenever anyone makes a donation to us or does anything uh they're often surprised when they get an email from me the same day just saying look really appreciate uh this it means a lot to us because uh it does absolutely and that was going to be my next question but i will make sure that it's on
关于我们和乔丹的故事也在上面。所以这会让你对你所做的工作，我们所做的工作，我应该说，有一个真正的感觉。但同时，你知道，如果任何人想支持我们的工作，我们有一个菜单，上面写着支持我们。你可以看到我们的筹款人，其他人所做的事情，从跑马拉松到爬山，做各种各样的事情来支持我们，没有那种支持，你知道，我们无法继续做我们所做的工作，所以每当有人给我们捐款或做任何事情时，他们经常会感到惊讶，当他们在同一天收到我的电子邮件，只是说，看，非常感谢，这对我们意义重大，因为，它确实。绝对，那将是我的下一个问题，但我会确保它在
all the show notes and in the emails related to this as well thank you so much for your time steve marion thank you for inviting me really enjoyed the conversation and uh yeah appreciate the invitation thank you so much oh what an absolute privilege it was to speak to steve we had some time both before and after the recording and we kind of got you know plans to stay in touch and to think about how we can continue this conversation. Please, if you do feel moved by what we've been discussing, do consider donating to the Jordan Legacy so that their work can be furthered to aim and strive for the zero suicide stats that would be just incredible. If you are listening or watching this because you have lost somebody or you're worried about somebody
所有的节目说明和相关的电子邮件中也是如此。非常感谢你的时间，史蒂夫。玛丽恩，谢谢你邀请我，非常喜欢这次谈话，而且，是的，感谢邀请，谢谢。哦，能和史蒂夫交谈真是一种绝对的荣幸。我们在录制前后都有一些时间，我们有计划保持联系，并思考我们如何能继续这次谈话。请，如果你确实被我们讨论的内容所感动，请考虑向乔丹遗产基金会捐款，以便他们的工作能够进一步推进，争取实现零自杀统计数据，那将是不可思议的。如果你正在收听或观看这个，因为你失去了某人，或者你担心某人，
then I'm so sorry to hear that you find yourself in that position. If you're watching this because you are considering that life might not be worth living please do make an appointment with your GP or if you feel like you can't keep yourself safe please do make contact with emergency services because what we know is that the emergency services are not just for broken bones. They are for kind of places of safety and emergency assessment for people who cannot feel that they can keep themselves safe. Please know that hope is possible and that the right services, the right treatment can lead to you having a richly enjoyable life. And if you're listening or watching this because you've lost somebody you love, and I'm so sorry to hear that, please look after yourself.
那么听到你发现自己处于那种境地，我感到非常抱歉。如果你正在观看这个，因为你正在考虑生活可能不值得活下去，请务必与你的全科医生预约，或者如果你觉得你无法保证自己的安全，请务必联系紧急服务部门，因为我们知道的是，紧急服务部门不仅仅是为了骨折。它们是为那些觉得无法保证自己安全的人提供安全和紧急评估的地方。请知道希望是可能的，正确的服务、正确的治疗可以引导你过上丰富愉快的生活。如果你正在收听或观看这个，因为你失去了你爱的人，听到这个我感到非常抱歉，请照顾好自己。
Ask people for support. Ask people for care. And yeah, you can follow me on social media. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent. Please do follow Steve Phillips on LinkedIn too. Please let me know what you think to this episode by coming along to the free Facebook group, which is the Aspiring Psychologist Community
向人们寻求支持。向人们寻求关怀。而且，是的，你可以在社交媒体上关注我。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。也请在LinkedIn上关注史蒂夫·菲利普斯。请通过加入免费的Facebook群组让我知道你对这一集的看法，那是“有抱负的心理学家社区”，
with Dr. Marianne Trent. And if you are grieving, you might find my book, The Grief Collective, useful. Thank you so much for your time in listening or watching this episode. If you're watching on YouTube, please do subscribe. Please do like, share and comment.
与玛丽安·特伦特博士一起。而且，如果你正在悲伤，你可能会发现我的书《悲伤集体》很有用。非常感谢你花时间收听或观看这一集。如果你正在YouTube上观看，请务必订阅。请务必点赞、分享和评论。
If you're listening on Spotify or wherever you get your podcasts, please do rate and review. Thank you so much for being part of my world and I will look forward to bringing you the next episode, which will be available from Saturday at 10am on YouTube and from 6am on Mondays wherever you get your podcasts. Thank you, take care. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical
如果你正在Spotify或任何你获取播客的地方收听，请务必评分和评论。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，我期待着为你带来下一集，它将于周六上午10点在YouTube上提供，并从周一上午6点开始在任何你获取播客的地方提供。谢谢，保重。有这个播客在你身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是“有抱负的心理学家播客”。与玛丽安·特伦特博士一起。我的名字是贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生，我阅读了临床
psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现这本心理学家合集非常有趣，书中讲述了各种不同的故事，以及人们是如何成为临床心理学家的。各种通往这一职业的途径之多令我惊叹，成为临床心理学家并没有所谓的“完美路径”。这让我充满了信心，意识到我并没有走错路，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。